hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear and on today's movie review gonna
be talking about some british horror
this is the movie kill list from 2011.
now ever since i can't believe this came
out all the way back in 2011. holy [ __ ]
now it's like well i feel like ever
since it came out i've been hearing
about how good it was and i just somehow
never got around to watching it and i
was just kind of like uh yeah i really
need to get to that someday because it
keeps coming up on like every single
list of you know best horror movies of
the 2010s best british horror from the
last 20 years best this and that so it's
just kind of like okay well i really
really have to watch that so finally uh
shutter actually added it a couple weeks
back so i was like okay well now i don't
have any excuse so now i'm for sure
gonna watch it and i have to say this
was pretty kick-ass it's kind of hard to
talk about without spoiling because i
will say it does have a quote-unquote
twist ending
and i know that that was you know even
though this was a pretty universally i
don't want to say universally but a very
widely praised horror movie um i think
the sticking point for a lot of people
that made it kind of like divisive was
the ending because this and for some
reason like even though it came out back
in 2011 i was somehow miraculously able
to
uh not have it spoiled for me which i
thought was kind of neat so i didn't
actually know like where it was going um
you knew it was going in a weird
direction just because of the
foreshadowing and stuff but you weren't
entirely sure where it was going so i'm
actually glad that i didn't know because
i think it's better not to like i said
this does seem to be but the the ending
of it does seem to be the the thing
where some people are just kind of like
ah i liked it up until then and then
they kind of ruined it or it got to i
don't want to say silly because it's not
but
you know it got too weird or it went too
out there or whatever but honestly i
really liked the ending um so
like you know your mileage may vary i
don't like i said i don't know if i want
to spoil it or not although some of the
comparisons
that i could make about it probably
would spoil it so i don't even know if
i'm gonna i don't know we'll we'll
figure it out when we get there but yeah
so as i said this came out in 2011 and
it was directed by ben wheatley who also
did the uh quite rad a field in england
which i need to i've seen that and i
actually need to do a review of that as
well because that's actually a really
good movie too this one is really kind
of a different thing though and honestly
it's a horror movie it's very violent
but i think i would call it more of a
crime thriller but it kind of goes more
horror
e like in the very last like the third
act
so it's still like legitimately a horror
movie although for most of it it's kind
of like you know i've seen it the the
first part at least compared to like
kind of like ken loach or like alan
clark um you know type movies where it's
just kind of like i don't want to say
like a kitchen sink drama but it is kind
of like a crime thriller with a lot of
kind of
interpersonal [ __ ] going on in there
like between friends and between like
husband and wife and and honestly all
that stuff was great and when i was like
reading the wikipedia page apparently
what they like ben wheatley when he got
all the actors on board they basically
he didn't really like he had a script
obviously but
that he let them kind of all develop
their own characters so a lot of the
stuff in the movie that you see is is
them kind of ad-libbing because they
were so familiar with their characters
and with the other actors characters
that you know they'd spent so much time
working on it that they were able to um
pretty much ad-lib all their lines and
honestly um i think that was a that was
something that really went toward
making this such a great movie is that
ever like all the interactions in it are
very
natural they're very like organic like
you can totally believe that these are
real people you know these two guys are
like really friends this is really a
husband and wife this is you know what i
mean it's just very very organic the way
everything is done and so it didn't
surprise me when i found out that it all
been largely ad-libbed just from them
working on their characters like before
they shot it so the story of this
there's two guys jay and gal now
you find out pretty quickly and like i
said this isn't a spoiler because i
think this is even in the description of
the movie
that both of them are hitmen they were
both uh in the british army at some
point and a lot of things are alluded to
in their past
and i kind of like that they leave a lot
of stuff ambiguous um another thing that
i read too was that ben wheatley
actually filmed a lot of stuff that's
referred to in this like oh that job
they botched like back in kiev or
whatever
um they filmed a lot of that but then in
the end like he took a bunch of it out
because he thought that it would be
better to leave everything kind of
ambiguous and i think that was actually
the right decision because
this is another one where i think would
um if you watched it a few more times
you would probably pick up a lot more
stuff because there is a lot of stuff in
there there's a lot of foreshadowing in
there like a lot of the um
conversations they have in the beginning
kind of come to fruition later on and
i'm not sure you know i think it's one
of those ones where like if you watch it
more times than that like you'll pick up
like you know it'll be this much richer
experience you'll pick up like all these
other details and stuff
but yeah so
uh gal
he seems to have been uh doing the
hitman jobs like all along but jay
hasn't done one for eight months uh so
he had i guess for that last job he made
like 40 000 pounds
but it's gotten to the point now like he
has a wife named shell and they have a
son
uh who's i can't remember how old the
son is i kind of feel like he's maybe
eight or nine or maybe he's a little bit
older they're kind of running out of
money
and uh shell is just kind of like look
you've been laying around this house
like being lazy and doing nothing for
eight months
and he does stuff like he's like well i
need money to like fix my to fix his hot
tub and he's like i need the hot tub
like for my back and all this other
stuff and then like he'll go to the
grocery store and buy like
20 bottles of wine and no toilet paper
it's like he's that kind of stuff he's
like this kind of schlubby you know lazy
dude that sits around um so yeah so him
and shel like at the beginning of this
are just at each other's throats all the
time now shell it should be noted she's
swedish well she has a british accent
but she talks she speaks swedish to her
mom on the phone and she says later that
she was she served in the swedish
military so
she is absolutely aware that jay uh and
gal are hitmen and it's kind of i don't
know if they're um implying that she did
it too or if she's just kind of like
okay with it or whatever because she's
definitely like trained like in shooting
and stuff like that so it could be but
like i said that was another thing they
kind of just left
maybe maybe not
uh but they're having like a bunch of
fights and uh they're she's like look
it's we're running out of money and um
we really need to you really need to
like get back to work
because you've just been laying around
so they have this dinner party and gal
shows up uh with this new girl that he's
been seeing named fiona
and uh stuff gets kind of like they
drink a lot and then stuff gets kind of
tense
and um jay and shell get into this
massive massive fight and it's just this
big embarrassing scene but then after
they drink more and everybody just kind
of like chills out about it
now uh gal
basically says to jay he's like look i
have a job you still are welcome to come
back and do it with me if you want to
and we'll go back because they used to
work together all the time
and uh so he's like it's just it's three
people uh you know they'll give you a
list of three people and it's you know
however much money it is so jay finally
agrees uh to do this because like i said
he's out of money
now
as they go about rubbing out the people
that are on the kill list i should know
too
that that something kind of like i said
and this is one of the things early on
in the film that sort of like hints that
things are going to go in like a weirder
direction later on
um is that fiona the girl that gal
brought to the dinner party like i said
they've been dating for a while but he
doesn't know her super well
she says she's a like in human resources
or whatever like she fires people
and uh during the dinner party she
actually goes off to the bathroom
and she takes down their mirror and put
and draws this like scratches this weird
symbol in the back of the mirror and
then puts the mirror back on the wall
and then there's like a a piece of
toilet paper that jay used earlier
because he like cut when he was shaving
or whatever and there's blood on it and
then she takes it and like tucks it into
her bra
so you're kind of led to believe she's
like okay well obviously she's into some
weird [ __ ] or she knows some [ __ ] that's
going on or she's maybe not the person
that you think she is so they kind of
like plant seeds like that early on so
basically like the bulk of the film
after that is jay and gal um going about
fulfilling their contract which is like
three people
and just like uh um it's kind of like i
said like a lot of um you know british
crime thriller sort of thing where it's
like you know the screen will go black
and this it'll be the first victim is
quote unquote the priest and then they
kind of just show them so they'll be
like in their car like shooting the [ __ ]
or whatever and they're like watching
the priest and then you know when they
go in and do the job and everything like
that
and then uh the second one though
you know the first one goes you know
without a hitch everything's fine uh the
weird thing about that one though is
that before he shoots the priest
the priest basically just like looks at
him like he's not even like upset about
it like he's not even mad about it that
he's about to get killed and he
basically like looks at jay and says
thank you and jay's like okay that's a
little weird having people thank me for
that i'm gonna like you know bump them
off but okay there's some weirdest shits
happen
uh but yeah so that one goes fine
but then the second one uh the second
victim that's on the contract on the
kill list is called the librarian
and what ends up happening with this guy
is that for whatever reason
jay who
it's um it sort of implied that the
previous eight months you know since he
had done his last job and he just kind
of been laying around and living off the
money that he made
is that he really
maybe doesn't either doesn't have the
stomach for it anymore or maybe he's
kind of like maybe losing it a little
bit like he's having a little bit of an
i don't know if i want to say like a
nervous breakdown but he's like not he's
not real mentally like as sharp as he
used to be i guess
so they've kind of like implied that uh
that maybe that's why he was kind of
getting out of it like he's having some
he seems to be having like some
issues like keeping control of his anger
so they do kind of like uh lead up to
that a lot and like i said he does kind
of like fight with his wife a lot going
up to this point so even though the
first uh the first kill goes fine
without a complete without a
complication when they go to do the
second one the librarian they're
actually like watching him it's like
staking him out
and he comes out of this warehouse
because the thing about it is that the
guy that gives them the kill list or
gives them the contract he doesn't tell
them like why they're killing these
people and he's just based like here's
their name here's their picture here's
where they're gonna be
um you figure out like when's the best
time to pop them or whatever but they
don't he doesn't tell him like why
they're being killed so they go and
they're like the librarian they're
watching him and he comes out
and for whatever reason jay's kind of
like i'm gonna go in that warehouse
where he just came out of because he's i
guess at first like maybe he suspects or
maybe he's like curious
as to why they're killing this dude
because he said he doesn't look like
anything he said he looks like nothing
but then the other guy is like yeah they
always look like nothing so why is this
dude different
but what ends up happening is that they
go into the warehouse that he came out
of and there's all this videos and stuff
in there and you're led they don't show
them to you but you're kind of led to
believe that maybe it's like snuff films
or you know like human trafficking type
stuff
and uh whatever they see in those movies
makes jay so angry that he's like i'm
not only gonna kill this dude i'm also
gonna kill like all his associates that
we found who were totally not even on
the contract it's like a freebie
and uh at this point like i said up to
this it's kind of just been like a crime
thriller uh where it's just like kind of
a lot of domestic drama you know a lot
of the friends hanging out stuff like
that it's a very grim
tone it's like you know it's funny but
it's funny in the way that like some
british crime thrillers are funny you
know what i mean where it's just like
the the interactions between the
characters are funny uh at this point
like when he goes to the librarian's
house like to kill him then it starts to
be like not funny anymore because this
scene wow
this is one of the most like he
basically beats the dude to death with a
hammer and like so he's like breaking
his knees and he's breaking his hand and
it's just like and i mean like i said i
know it's fake it's a movie but even i
was watching movie going god damn i was
like that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
it's it's pretty [ __ ] up honestly like
the way they did the special effects i
was like it looks like he's actually
like beating the dude with the hammer
and it's just like [ __ ] crazy but see
even before like after he's he beats the
dude like in the knee and stuff so the
guy's still alive and everything but
even though he's doing that this guy is
doing the same thing that the priest did
and he's saying to jay he says gal like
goes into the other room to do something
and
the the dude like the victim like says
to him it's like he doesn't know who you
are does he and jay's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about and then he starts
saying
it was nice to have met you
and then like he also like when he
starts beating him with a hammer he
keeps saying thank you thank you and
he's like what the [ __ ] like why are
these people thanking me for killing
them i don't understand it so it's like
you know that like something really
really weird is going on then they
actually that went so awry uh he made
such a mess like in the kitchen like i
said normally like the priest you just
pop him in the head they had all the
plastic out already so they just popped
and rolled them up in the thing and then
threw them in the incinerator or
whatever and it was just like you know
it was super easy and clean but this one
obviously you beat somebody to death
with a hammer uh pro tip you're gonna
leave like a huge mess and a lot of
evidence so gal is just pretty much like
what the [ __ ] is the matter with you and
then then for jay to like be so angry at
like what he saw in these videotapes and
he's like i'm not only gonna kill this
guy i'm gonna go and like kill his
associates too which wasn't even part of
the package
so
obviously he's starting to lose his [ __ ]
at this point gal's like look maybe we
can get out of the contract you
obviously are not uh you know ready for
this anymore and it's just kind of like
we're gonna get in trouble and uh you
know maybe the guy will just if if we
find replacements uh to kill the last
guy on the kill list you know maybe
he'll let us out of the contract uh
spoiler alert he doesn't uh so they
basically have to go through with the
last thing so as i said i really
oh i really really don't want to spoil
how this ends because
and honestly if you've seen it let me
know if you liked the ending or not
because like i said the ending does seem
to be kind of divisive but i will say as
i said even though the like the first
and second act of this are basically a
straight up super violent british crime
thriller the last act of it goes in a
much more
in a much more horror direction i was
going to say the subgenre but that'll
just ruin it so i'm not going to but all
this stuff that like ev what everybody
was saying to him the whole time like
before they killed him and stuff like
before he killed them like thanking him
and it's like saying they don't know who
you are and stuff like that all of that
plays out like later on but as i said
it's kind of left
ambiguous
as to
what like necessarily like what the
reason was
what so like i said it's really really
hard to say without spoiling what it is
but
if you know you know like if you've seen
the end uh you know what i'm talking
about and i really want i'm curious to
know like how people feel about the
ending of this because i thought it was
good like i thought it was really cool i
thought it was a cool way to end it and
i didn't really see it coming i mean i
kind of did because
you know you knew something strange was
happening because of
the weird way that people were acting
like the weird [ __ ] that fiona was doing
with the mirror and you know the weird
uh stuff people were saying to him like
before he killed them so you knew there
was some kind of like bigger
plot or like some bigger thing going on
but you didn't know exactly what
direction it was going in and i thought
it was like really cool not knowing so i
probably am not going to spoil it but i
will say
that
i just i thought this was great i
thought this was like a great
very tense very violent
movie and it's like you know i i tend to
like british horror anyway and i like
british crime thrillers also um and this
seemed like a good amalgam of crime
thriller with a more straight-up horror
angle like toward the end and i thought
it was really really well done um all
the character work fantastic all the
acting was great like i said very very
natural and totally believable like i
totally bought into the family dynamic i
totally bought into jay and gal being
like best friends who would like work
together tons and tons and like all
their banter back and forth like really
funny but
like you could tell that they were best
friends and they loved each other and
they'd like been through some [ __ ]
together and stuff like that and it was
just
um like i said i guess because they
worked on their characters so much that
they were able to just like ad-lib just
like you know like they were regular
people and that's exactly how it came
across so all the acting in this was
fantastic and uh like i said the
violence is it's it happens like it's
not
wall-to-wall violence like i said it
takes a while actually for that really
bad like that hammer thing to happen
hammer time
for hammer time but when it does happen
it is very
very violent it's one of those things
where
even if you've seen like a lot of
slasher movies and stuff you know
watching somebody get beaten in the head
with a hammer like and it looks real
that's still like kind of hard to watch
so if you don't really like violent [ __ ]
like that but like you know really
realistic then maybe this wouldn't be
your cup of tea because especially that
hammer thing holy crap that was just
like that was like really
even i winced i have to say and like i
said i've seen pretty much everything
but
yeah i went to seeing that and like i
said it looked really really real but uh
but yeah so let me know if you've seen
it uh it's on shutter at the moment like
i said i'm sure it's probably on other
streaming services as well and i'm glad
i finally got around to watching it
because like i said what it's been out
for like [ __ ] 10 years and i uh i
guess i kind of slept on it like all
this time i kept it seeing like i kept
seeing it get recommended and i was like
i love british horror movies i should
probably watch that and it's like but it
just took me so long but then finally
shutter added it so yeah i finally got
to watch it and it's great i loved it i
thought it was fantastic just a great
great movie all around very enjoyable so
uh yeah so if you've seen it tell me
what you thought about the ending
if you're going to spoil it in the
comments i guess maybe put spoiler and
then put like
hit enter a bunch of times something
like that so it's like people don't want
to know but you know it's like i said
it's kind of hard to talk about without
saying
what that ending is but
let me know did you like it did you
think it was dumb just i don't know i'm
curious to see uh how everybody felt
about it so yeah that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye